a Marcia Dorsky executive director
Center for genetics and society sorry
the pedal has agency so what did you
decide to do you're doing a round table
you have slides
[Music]
okay so this panel has structured itself
and the participants are as I said
Marcia Dorsky executive director Center
for genetics and society Alondra Nelson
the president social science research
council Oh soggy oppa soggy bioethics
and medicine from Berkeley and Erin
Panofsky sociology of science UCLA
Institute for society and genetics thank
you so thanks again for being with us so
we decided to change things up a bit so
a few weeks ago Morris and I were
talking about what to talk about in this
panel and we realized the conversate is
the conversation that we were having was
probably instructive for the group and
so we figured that we figured it that
it'd be good to kind of have more of a
conversation among all four of us and as
opposed to individual presentations just
it's a way to kind of get at fee issues
in a different way so each of us work on
different aspects of science and
technology but algorithms and the
question of algorithmic fairness are not
squarely in the wheelhouse of any of our
work so today we're going to draw upon
our experiences and insights with
regards to how race has been used and
conceptualized in other technological
spaces and hopefully provide some
insight on what this work might mean for
the way that we think about machine
learning and bias so we start off with
each panelist of I'll introduce a piece
panels briefly and each each one of us
will spend a few minutes just talk about
how our existing work relates to the
question of this of this meeting
so mark Sarnoff's key executive director
at center for genetics and society marcy
least one talk for a few minutes about
how the work that you do at CGS connects
with the conversation we're having today
sure thank you a second thanks to Pat
and Cynthia for organizing and bringing
us all together so the Center for
genetics and society is a nonprofit
organization a public interest
organization we're based here in
Berkeley we're just down the street on
University Avenue and I should say that
some of our folks are here today Katie
and Katherine and Kayla and osaki has
been associated with the Center for
genetics and society for a lot of years
on
so our mission is to bring a social
justice and public interest perspective
to assessing the social implications of
a range of human bio technologies and
with that in that category we include
human genetic technologies and we
include assisted reproduction and we
think that this lens this social justice
Public Interest Human Rights lens will
tell us some important things about how
these technologies have been and should
be developed deployed marketed
understood and governed so we do some
policy advocacy work we do a lot of
communications work and we have over the
years try to gather around us a network
of scholars and public interest
advocates from whom we have learned
enormous ly and deeply and many of them
are in this room so that's another kind
of thanks that I need to give so say a
couple more things and try to link to
algorithms just in a couple minutes so
the the the mission that we have this
idea of bringing a social justice
perspective to human bio technologies it
seems to strike a lot of people as a
really odd idea and the idea that we
should learn and we can learn from the
histories the social context
specifically the histories of scientific
racism and eugenics the social context
of structural inequalities and racism
this idea is not one that's obvious to a
lot of people so part of our work is
honestly just telling people that there
is an important connection that should
be made there but I think you know we
obviously - it is obvious to a lot of
people I think it became obvious to us
because of the moment that we were
founded which is back in 2001 so this
was the time just after the mapping of
the human genome a few years after dolly
the cloned sheep and the controversies
about human reproductive cloning and
research cloning that came up
around that a few years not that many
years after the publication of the bell
curve that we've talked about today and
the ongoing pushback against this
pernicious ideas in that book and also
we were formed in the middle of a
chapter of an of a almost now forgotten
earlier chapter of controversy about the
idea the prospect of heritable genome
modification and that was one of the
main motivations for founding a public
interest organization to look at this
range of technologies so we know that
I'm sure everyone in this room has read
the headlines of the babies in China the
CRISPR babies in China well back then
there was also a group of scientists
bioethicists futurists a small but vocal
group who were very excited about the
idea that we were now learning enough
now that we had mapped the human genome
when the head learned to read it we were
gonna be able to rewrite it so so that's
where we got our start and as I
mentioned that you know we have been
privileged and honored to work with
scholars across a range of disciplines
recently more with science and life
scientists than we have in the past who
some of whom have reached out to us but
also sociologists anthropologists legal
and policy experts and also with the
range of social justice advocates so
people whose work is not in the act of
the Academy but in communities working
on racial justice reproductive justice
disability justice and LGBTQ justice and
rights so just to mention a few of the
areas of concern that crossed more
closely with the topics of today we have
actually tried to really do some work
connecting the history of scientific
racism and eugenics to the eugenic
temptations that I would that I think
have hung over today and to the racism
that is embedded in a lot of
biotechnology and biomedicine that we've
talked about already too
so we've really tried to track this
resurgence of ideas about racial
classifications being based being you
know it's a real basis in biology rather
than being social social constructions
with a hierarchical assumption built
into it we've looked at the debates
around race genetics and IQ one phrase
that I would like to bring into this
conversation that I was surprised hasn't
come up yet today is this idea of
polygenic scores the idea that you can
have a single number that's gonna
predict educational attainment that's
found in the genes independent of
society history economy and then we've
also worked on some of the specific
applications of human bio technology's
DNA forensics and the very important
implication implications of the
disproportionate contact between
communities of color and law enforcement
and how that is reflected in and shapes
the way that DNA forensics are used and
one thing that didn't come up but we
have a lot of experts who have looked at
it in this room the idea about race
specific medicines something that we've
tried to like communicate to public's
and finally the idea of ancestry tests
and again a lot of the people in this
room are people who have been on that
for 10 15 years and the way that racial
categories are implicated in these
ancestry tests so these are all things
that are ways that data databases data
in databases algorithms genome-wide
Association studies that are being
turned into polygenic scores we look at
the way that these are translated into
popular culture into through the media
into political culture and some of those
are the kinds of things that I want to
give you examples of later great great
thank you so next we have a laundry
Nelson who is the president of the
Social Science Research Council and
professor of sociology at Cologne
on our way to the Institute for Advanced
Study so if you could share a few
thoughts with how you're working next
what connects with the theme of the
conference well Marcy covered kind of
the whole spectrum I think of what many
of us have been doing for almost the
last 15 years but I would just add that
you know I think that the the sort of
moment of 21st century genetics in which
you have the sort of marriage of you
know what you know the eugenics
temptation one might call it or that
sort of longer history of genetics with
supercomputing becomes a moment that
necessitates algorithms because you've
just got a lot more information and so
for for I think many of us in this room
we've been working on genetics the
headline has never been algorithms our
algorithmic bias right we've been
actually talking about this work in a
different way but certainly over the
last I mean even my earlier work about
the late 20th century was also about
genetics to some extent but tracing that
work is really also tracing a kind of
history of algorithms and in my case
because I work with often local
communities are interested in sort of
how scientific ideas sort of travel on
the ground it's been also a kind of way
another slice of it is sort of how local
communities have been engaging with the
sort of rise of algorithms as they come
to have increasing social and political
force and next we have Aaron Panofsky
who's an associate professor at UCLA
Institute for Society in genetics and
also in public policy and sociology
thanks I first of all I just want to say
thank you for the invitation to come
here I think that this has been a really
fascinating conversation I think it's
really important to have more
conversations like this that tried to
cross disciplinary lines in a spirit of
kind of like openness in exchange where
people are really interested in learning
from each other so I connect so I'll say
one thing about the institution I work
at and then a little bit about my
research so I work at this place called
the Institute for Society in genetics at
UCLA it's different than the Center for
genetics and society right so what we're
we're essentially a department
UCLA and we're very broadly
interdisciplinary in that we have
sociologists like me historians of
science anthropologists of science and
technology but also primatologists and
epigenetics is to basically poisons
little nematode worms and sees what
happens to their - there are future
generations we have a medical
anthropologist we have a scientist ioan
studies science technology studies
scholar coming in and so forth so we
have oh and we have a scholar of race
and religion so so we have this very
sort of broad interdisciplinary group of
people and there others that I didn't
mention but but what I want to say is
that what we're really trying to get at
is how can you have a community that
moves beyond the sort of the sort of
intractable sort of pools of
conversations about what inheritance or
heredity means in society right we don't
you know have the nature people and the
nurture people and have them Duke it out
we have we try to have a sort of a
broader conversation about different
ways of framing these questions and
problems and the way we do this is you
know on the one hand you know a huge
amount of our time is devoted to
figuring out like when we can have a
common faculty meeting right because
like everyone has a joint appointment
anyway so that's that's the real problem
with interdisciplinary exchange is not
actually the intellectual stuff it's
like how can we find a common meeting
time but but but when we do talk about
the intellectual stuff we spend a lot of
time talking about how do we educate our
students right so we have an
interdisciplinary major and minor and I
think this is the kind of thing actually
that is really important to think about
in an educational institution like
Berkeley in an institution that's trying
to think about how do we sort of
theorize computing and theorize
artificial intelligence for the future
right so how do we train students in a
new way so it's not just okay all you're
being trained in is the math and then
once you are a fully formed intellectual
and competent in that
then maybe you can think about social
issues when you go to a collective
meeting right can we can we start
earlier on and to think about the
entanglement and embeddedness of how in
our case genetics and society biology
and society biology history
dipper forms of inheritance different
forms of of Health different definitions
of structure agency things like that how
all that stuff can be embedded in ways
of thinking about the problem of human
health human human biology and it's and
its social and ethical meanings so
that's that's one dimension of what we
do so we spend a lot of time trying to
think about how to do that in teaching
and then actually in some ways a smaller
portion of what we do is engage in
collaborative research projects and part
of that is because it's difficult you
know to you can't articulate a problem
that is so interdisciplinary that brings
that 10 list of scholars that I Liv
mention to you all into one problem area
but you know there's lots of like you
know binary and and triples of people
that are engaged in collaborations apply
for grants and things like that but I
think it's a really effective way of
thinking about how can you bring new how
can you move conversations forward that
are not after all the research has been
done right so hey I made a an A
algorithm and it can diagnose bias in in
this linguistic corpus that's awesome
but like how might that problem be
transformed if the undergraduate
research assistants and the undergrad
and and the graduate students and the
postdocs and the scholars had been
educated in a different train that's not
to be critical of the model and the
efforts of to try to confront this stuff
as it is but how might the
transformation take place if we thought
about education a little bit differently
so that's that's where where we come
from in that so it's a it's a different
way in which we're public facing than
the Center for Society Engine Center for
genetics and society is right so we
think we're trying to think about I mean
one of the main ways we try to think
about this is through an educational
mission I wish we were a little bit more
public facing wish we had the sort of
resources and
and wherewithal to do more of anyway
some public stuff but the day is young
so and then the then let me talk for a
second about my own research and one
thing that I want to so I'm a
sociologist of science and I think a lot
about how science gets made and under
what conditions it gets made and one of
the things that I've been thinking about
a lot in this conversation is we have
sort of in this implicit discussion
about bias being like a problem that we
need to solve so let's devious our our
estimates or D bias our core purposes
and stuff and I think one thing that
that I've a theme that I keep coming
back oh and how do we be more so so de
bias how do we make our research less
ambiguous so it can be more precise
about the sort of terms and the meanings
that we use this is something everyone
was talking about in the database that
she was talking about and I guess the
the point that I keep coming back to in
my research is the ways that bias and
the ways that ambiguity are functional
and I don't necessarily mean in a good
way but that they serve positive
functions for the authority of expert
cultures and some of this is because you
know the the deep nature of something
like race says like Stuart Hall a long
time ago and even before this but Stuart
Hall a long time ago called
race a floating or a sliding signifier
right it's a thing that gains its power
or pasa partly through its poly see me
it's it's our inability to pin it down
or anytime you pin it down one way oh
did you mean this that's bias oh no I
didn't mean this I meant this and that
oh no no we didn't mean this we meant
this right so like there's a way in
which it's ambiguity the way it
straddles between different sort of
forms of meaning and different
definitions is part of what gives it its
power and authority and so that's like a
very that's interesting right because
because when we're doing things like
machine learning my sense is that what
we're trying to do is disambiguate make
more solid connections and so forth okay
and then in in bias I can tell you
vignettes from my research later on but
the biased thing is that I
that actually uh you know feels like
behavioral genetics fields like
polygenic prediction gained power in
part by speaking in ways that are on the
edge of improper and illegitimate
improperly and legitimately about race
and racial differences right so it's not
just is and this is people who have good
hearts right this is not people who have
malice in their heart there are those
people out there
Harriet talked about some of them Evelyn
talked about some of them right so there
are the Charles Murray's the the Philip
Russians the Cartwright's back in
history but there are also people that
now are I think on that that they gain
authority and power in their fields
partly by being willing to speak in ways
about things like race and racial
differences that touch on illegitimate
illegitimate claims about racial
differences in intelligence and in terms
of my own work so I'm a professor of
bioethics here at Berkeley I'm in the
joint medical program in School of
Public Health so a lot of my work looks
at the social political and historical
context that gave rise to the field of
bioethics in the mid twentieth century
and understanding how those the lessons
we learn from that moment can be applied
to contemporary concerns here in
medicine and science but with that I'm
also very much interested in how we can
apply some new lessons about the the
birth and growing pains of bioethics as
applied to other fields in science
technology including things such as
machine learning so being able to kind
of draw connections and learn from one
another I think is a at least for me a
key part of my work so for so for NYX
how much time do you have
okay great great so reason I have a
conversation and talked about a few
things that that we find important both
in terms of our own work as applied to
this conversation right now on
algorithmic justice and I think a good
place to start is Khan werein end up
ended up and is innocent statement so
how do we typically think about bias
when talking about race and technologies
so what assumptions and frameworks are
at play and if you can jump in on that
so okay so I should say I should just
say that I'm like have a lot of iron
around bias conversation and I think
it's the wrong conversation to be having
about social inequality about racial
inequality or generally I think there
are lots of reasons why that we you know
that as we talk about bias it's either
present or not present rather than you
know bias being something that's that'd
be phenomenal as we talk about bias to
Aaron's point I think that it's easy to
forget that it's not a system you know
the bias systems work to amplify
powerful ends and so that in some ways
is often the intention of them not the
accident of them I worry that
particularly for machine learning
artificial intelligence and other kinds
of sophisticated systems that we talk
too much about bias as being a kind of
$0.20 through country racism and that
that's not useful so we get very caught
up in things that drives me quite
literally insane like the viral video
for the racist soap dispenser like don't
care right like you know I really don't
care you know and so we so we're stuck
we get caught in this sort of trap as
bias as exclusion or bias as it takes me
longer to get soap and it's a kind of
anemic and and not I think particularly
either politically or intellectually
useful way so it's this kind of very
anemic inclusion and diversity sort of
paradigm for talking about machine
learning and algorithm plication zuv the
algorithmic turn and I think it also
like for as an analytic tool as scholars
of inequality as scholars of race and
technology it also like puts us
a way of talking about race that doesn't
appreciate the dynamism of it and what
it is in this moment so one of my kind
of examples often when people are
talking about class we don't have a
problem talking about the sort of ways
that class has changed over time or
capitalism has changed over time from
pre-industrial to neoliberal and there's
lots of other things in between that
we'll talk about but we have I think a
challenge in talking about the dynamism
of racial bias and racism and for me the
way that we're talking about bias now is
a hurdle it's it's a sort of this it's
one of these moments in which we're not
sort of saying what is the moment in
which we're living in and how is the
race of this moment and the racism and
the by of disability different from
moments that have preceded it and I
think we need to grapple with their
question there are things that are the
same right the sort of issues around
classification issues around hierarchy
issues around notions of intellectual
inferiority and superiority those things
are evergreen right but there's also a
way in which race is operating in racism
differently now one of the ways I think
that we have to think about that is that
it is it's systemic right and I think
that if we're going to understand how
bias works in algorithmic systems we
need to understand that it's not just
the intentions of a one bad or good
actor it's not just the intentions of
one good or one bad algorithm it's how
the actor and the algorithm Trant you
know moves around in a system and in a
process and so for me for social
scientists what is a way of thinking
about the world and about issues that
arise visa the kind of machine learning
artificial intelligence and alike that
are systemic and scale similar to the
phenomenon that we're studying right and
that are dynamic and the way that they
operate right and so the bias again for
me is sort of present or not presidents
not like you know someone makes a
meteorological algorithm and it ends up
being a predictive policing algorithm
like how do we get there but that's
that's true that's that's where we you
know but like it's not you know and I
think a lot of our conversation leads us
to say like oh there was a really bad
computer science engineer and it's you
know his or her fault and that's why
we've got bias and this is
all of the things that happen as we go
from meteorology to predictive
predictive policing need to be part of a
social science apparatus for thinking
about bias not just the kind of one
actor the one system the one thing the
one moment so that's what I would sort
of offer and that said I think if we can
think about bias in a systematic way
that it actually could be not only
conceptually but politically useful
right so if you can show how a kind of
supply chain of bias operates whether or
not it's intentional or unintentional
whether and how you go from sort of
provenance to the use of say an
algorithm then it allows us to actually
talk about the complexity of inequality
as a response to that so there's a case
study I want us to talk through in
addition but all I'll sort of stop there
so let me I want to let me tell you the
the the like short version of that study
I alluded to that I that I did about the
field of behavioral genetics early on
and some of the ways that I think that
bias what we might think of what I mean
we might label now as bias what others
might label as racism play the kind of
functional role okay so here's the story
so so I wrote a book called misbehaving
science which kind of historical and
sociological account of the field of
behavioral genetics these the guys to
talk about genes for IQ personality
criminality and so forth and so in one
part of the study I looked at the way
that behavioral geneticists this field
that this this broad field of
psychologists and geneticists and
psychiatrist and others dealt with
people like Arthur Jensen so he was this
major G theorist and into in theorists
of of IQ and set off in the early 70s
that IQ debate which was basically his
his string of reasoning was you know
everything from Mouse studies to twin
studies shows that IQ is heritable
everything from our studies about
about education suggests that IQ can't
be changed very much by educational
interventions we're talking this is also
written in 1969 so things changed but
this argument everything shows that the
black white IQ gap is wide and enduring
and and when we string all these things
together it suggests that the black
white IQ gap is genetically determined
and that therefore we're wasting our
time and money and effort talking about
things like and this is literally what
his conclusion was things like head
start right we should not be trying to
do compensatory education because we're
just throwing good money after bad and
we're not you know if IQ is genetically
determined and racial and the reason is
that African Americans are genetically
less capable of learning and knowing
that's it QED and so he so he wrote
about that and then you have people like
Philip Rushton who wasn't mentioned but
he was another figure in this field he
had more provocative theories about the
sort of evolutionary history of whites
and blacks this is a penises right so
yeah he had a RK theory which was about
the dis the the Archaea life history
people know what this is right so this
is basically our do you have a strategy
of having lots of spreading lots of
gametes into the world and not caring
about them or investing heavily in your
offspring and so do you are you like an
elephant and you raise one baby for six
years or are you like a sea urchin and
you spread you know 10 million gametes
every you know every time I just like
let it go that way right so that's what
sort of our key theory is trying to get
at and he said no this explains racial
behavioral differences right so you have
whites and Asians who invest heavily in
their in their babies and are very
sexually responsible and civilizational
II complex and you have black people who
are sexually promiscuous and and don't
invest in their babies and don't care
about the intelligence of their babies
and so they have a different
evolutionary history and this is what
explains the sort of civilizational
differences between the three major
genetic three major races oh and also he
got to say the key wasn't racist because
he ranked age
above white so he wasn't a white
supremacist anyway okay anyway so so you
get these guys saying this stuff crazy
theories totally flawed you could just
top the top to bottom talk about all the
sort of flaws in this research and so I
interviewed a whole bunch of behavioral
geneticists about what do you think
about these guys and there were a couple
others in this in this camp and they
said stuff like oh man you know I first
of all like with Jensen they said stuff
like well he's he's he's brilliant I
don't know why he's so fixated on this
race stuff like if he just stuck with
the IQ if he just stuck with the twin
studies it'd be great but he keeps
bringing race into this I don't know why
he does that and so it's sort of like
okay so he's not and they would say he's
not a racist he just doesn't have the
kind of social sensors to know when
something's inappropriate so it's like
okay so he's not a racist it's just a
sociopath okay so but and then with with
with both of them they would say stuff
like look I just think we just think
that this is not good science right you
can't for lots of technical reasons and
for lots of sort of sociological reasons
you can't make the kinds of claims that
they want to make using the kinds of
technical tools that we have as
behavioral geneticists so I won't go
into that but that that would be the
kind of thing I would hear again and
again and again from the researchers but
they would say but we would defend to
death his right to do this under
principles of academic and intellectual
freedom and so that was a puzzle for me
because that's not what intellectual or
academic freedom is right so academic
freedom is the right to use science and
and and proper and legitimate canons of
scientific research and follow them
where they go not the right to say
whatever the hell you want that everyone
around you thinks is bad science and
misuses their research for your sort of
nefarious racist terms and and calls
that and and and and implements that in
your field does that make sense and
explain that very well right it's like
that's that's what scientific freedom is
supposed to be right not defending the
right to do bad science Devine you to do
the right to do good science even if it
leads to unwelcome conclusion
if you do bad science yes yes great good
point right right and so then they would
talk about their defending academic
freedom by defending his right to do
that stuff as opposed to defending their
academic freedom by attacking bad
science within their field right and so
that was part of my question in this so
there's a long historical reason why why
that happens but I wanted to talk about
just some of the functional symbolic
reasons because when I talked to people
about why okay so what you know why do
you sort of keep this race question in
there even if in the field even if you
don't think it's good science there were
three things they would talk about one
they would talk about it allowed the
legitimate behavioral geneticists to
establish their reasonableness on the
matter okay so they would say well okay
so we have Jenson and Russian on one
side but then you have like the Flat
Earth social scientists and sociologists
and anthropologists on the other side
and we occupy a kind of reasonable
middle that says that a partial
hereditary entire thesis has some
plausibility theoretical plausibility
even if we don't have the sort of the
the empirical tools to measure it okay
so that was one it allowed them to sort
of signal there between two camps
reasonableness a second thing it would
allow them to do is claim relevance
right like it's like this obscure stuff
about like which of the five factor
personality traits is heritable betweens
who cares but this race that's something
everything cares about and so one of
them talked to me about how like every
time it goes to a cocktail party you
know the first thing people ask them is
not about personality they ask me but
just tell me okay so what's the race
thing here right it gives them the
relevance that they're always on the
phone right the the the journalists
always want a quote from them it gives
them a reason to be much more important
than they're sort of marginal and sort
of problematic field right that's been
criticized in all these different ways
would otherwise be and and the third
thing is it allows them to a certain
kind of strength and independence from
their interlocutors right no we're going
to say we're going to follow the truth
where we where it goes or we're not
going to cau to the
the to the PC dictates of the Academy
right we we are an independent
intellectually powerful autonomous we
have our own judgment of what's
important questions right so and they
would say this is all the stuff that
they said so to me what I realized was
that they would defend something that
they believed was false basically or
unknowable but be but it also served
these other functions for that and I
think that that is so are there lessons
here for us more broadly right are there
lessons for I don't know I don't know
you know so like just the other day in
The New York Times there was the whole
thing about how YouTube keeps feeding
pedophilia right because because it
strings together a set of sort of
innocuous videos about children playing
and children in swimsuits and children
gallivanting and then after a while
you're like wait a minute this is
stringing together sort of so so is that
an error or is there something
functional going on is there something
beneficial going on for some logics in
the company anyway
yeah maybe I'll do a slightly different
take on this going back to the the
ancestry tests and I was just gonna so
it was really clear early on in the
development of these ancestry tests that
there was some serious you know
consequences here of talking about the
fact that we're gonna find ethnicity in
our genes and there was an article that
came out way back in 2007 in science
that was that several of the authors are
here with us that was included Alondra
and john khan and who else here were
we're on we're on the Joan Joan Fujimura
was on it and dueña was on that paper
and Jake Hoffman so this was a paper
called the science and business of
genetic ancestry testing remember that
and and one of the things they said was
these tests should not be seen as
determining the race or ethnicity of a
test taker
they cannot pinpoint the place of origin
or social affiliation of even one
ancestor with exact certainty and while
the websites of many companies state
that race is not genetically determined
the tests nevertheless promote the
popular understanding that race is
rooted in one's DNA so it was clear from
the beginning right but still see if I
can go forward to we had people who were
involved with this burgeoning industry
and it has continued to burgeon in it
you know like even the last few years
taking off in even a far greater way
with a spike in the number of people
whose DNA samples are now in these
proprietary private for-profit databases
this is back in 2008 for just a few
months after the science article I just
quoted from came out and it's an which
which kicky she
the founder of 23andme she was married
to Sergey Brin the one of the founders
of Google and she would talk about these
issues of race and here's how the way
she would talk about it we envision a
new type of community where people will
come together around specific genotypes
and these artificial barriers of country
and race will start to break down so
that was her promise and her intention
you know I mean let's you know we can
say that that was what she truly
believed perhaps and you know what
motivated her but then I think the
question that I'm trying to get at here
is how are these ideas translated the
Mandate of our panel was to look at
translational issues and so let's look
at how these ideas are translated into
what people have taken from the fact
that they're you know for Father's Day
for Mother's Day for you know any day of
any holiday you can think of get these
barage a--'s of advertising now for the
on television on radio for these
ancestry tests and is it making people
think that there is something biological
genetic that defines race well I think
it does and I think the company's
despite the claims on their websites
that they've been making since 2007 and
despite these kinds of statements the
companies sometimes slip up and they
make it really clear so I wanted to play
this 30-second ad if it'll play oops
nope want to go back
anyway know how to make this this is an
embedded video and it played on my
computer so this is an ad it's a
30-second ad that was all over
television during the 2018 Winter
Olympics yeah it won't okay so the
website says the website the ad shows
this Olympic skater and it talks about
her greatness and so the idea is where
does this greatness come from and
obviously the greatness comes from her
genes right and so as the narration goes
on we see that her greatness not only
comes in general from her genes it comes
48 percent from her Scandinavian genes
and I can't remember which is which
maybe the Scandinavian genes were the
ones that gave her her precision and the
Central Asian genes were the ones that
gave her her drive and the British genes
were the ones that gave her her grace
but this is not subtle so so I think
that this is the kind of you know
translational issue we need to be
grappling with because when we look at
how these ideas that are based on you
know massive databases of genetic
information that they've got some data
that shows them something you know this
is how it gets translated into popular
ideas and we you know we we can't
necessarily blame it on the the bad
computer scientists the bad database
analysts or even the bad co-founder of
the genetic testing company it's this is
stuff that is so embedded in our society
and in our ideas but
why isn't clear for whites expenses
three years for the fact that there
shouldn't be said I'm sorry
blame ancestry blame ancestry well I
think this is a pretty dramatic example
and ancestry should be blamed and should
be taken to task and that's you know
something that we you know small way
tried to do by publicizing this but I
think it's embedded in the entire
industry and I think what we're facing
is new ways where ideas of genetic
essentialism and race as biology are
getting promoted with the imprimatur of
cutting-edge science and technology so
that's a problem I think we face
so thank you see sure he said maybe
switch gears a little bit and talk about
specific technology so it might have
concerns about so so facial recognition
is becoming an interesting space where
algorithmic justice is interfacing with
the public so just a couple years ago
San Francisco banned use of facial
recognition technologies about a police
department and a few other agencies so
Alondra can you tell us a little bit
about what happened at the Atlantic Park
Towers so this is a case study that I've
been watching for a few months and that
I hope that we can have a conversation
about in part because it reveals that
the complexity of what we're dealing
here is more I thinks it is a bit more
dynamic and complex as I said before
then the issue of bias so this is a case
that's unfolding now in East New York
Brooklyn as as you said it's the
Atlantic packed out Park Towers which is
a rent regulated or rent stabilized
apartment in New York City where there
are in decreasing you know that's a
decreasing pool of things and the
landlord for this unit proposed last
summer to install what what a face it
effectively a facial wrap algorithm a
facial recognition system for people to
enter and the building so these are
these were formerly I mean there's all
sorts of things here and I'll just lay
out a few issues that I think get us
beyond a very simplistic bias
conversation and force us to actually
really have a compensate conversation
about intersecting incentives and other
kinds of contacts that are not only or
solely about the technology or an
algorithm so these are these were
formally mitchell-lama
apartment so they were formerly for
middle-class people in New York City the
apartment the the sort of company that
owns the apartment building had already
been engaged in hyper surveillance of
this community which is
disproportionately african-american
women senior citizens so there was
evidence that they were using cameras in
the building to see what people were
bringing in and out of their homes so
long before this became an issue about
facial algorithm they were using camera
to say well you're not supposed to have
a space heater in your apartment and our
camera is sort of absorbed you having a
space heater so it's already a context
of hyper heightened racialized gendered
in classed kind of surveillance into
which the facial recognition algorithm
is being proposed to enter so this is
like I kind of think the rub that I want
us to talk about I mean so for me we
talk often about sort of AI and machine
learning and sort of as mere
abstractions and as those of you who
know my work know I'm always interested
in sort of the translational piece which
is about how non-expert sort of deal
with this so whether or not it's
community activists of the 1970s were
early adopting consumers of
direct-to-consumer genetics and that the
21st early 21st century so in this case
the activists have taken up the language
of algorithmic bias right and so they
say as part of their challenge that
they're going to a state entity a New
York City body that has the permit that
has the authority to either grant this
or block this that the algorithms are
biased that we have seen reports and
data coming out of MIT and otherwise
that says that if you use these facial
algorithm systems on us they'll be
biased against us african-american women
in particular right so that's you know
we know that to be true in some
instances we don't know that necessarily
to be true of this particular system
which is called stone lock which was
developed particularly for various kinds
of uses and real estate markets and
housing
so the the challenge here of course is
that if your stone lock then you say
we're going to give you a more accurate
algorithm and we'll make sure you won't
be reaiiy denta fide misidentified by
our facial recognition out you know
algorithm that we are still going to
continue to use to you know allow you to
get into your building and I think that
it creates that there's a kind of
political vulnerability for vulnerable
communities around the use of a bias
claim because it is tied to a
technological fix and in this case you
know there's other issues of as I said
pre-existing hyper surveillance there's
issues of I mean this is East New York
which used to be sort of the
quote-unquote badlands of New York City
and of Brooklyn which is now being
rapidly gentrified in part because they
rezone this area from being industrial
but to making it for residential real
estate in 2016 so this is coming just on
the the heels you know two years of a
sort of radical rezoning and so I feel
like the bias conversation which is like
you know again goes back to this like
we're not included in the database and
so we're going to be miss recognized is
a kind of 20th century kind of civil
rights trope that's not particularly
efficacious for 21st century tactics of
racism which include algorithms and
algorithmic tools but also are nested in
these kind of complex systems of racial
dynamics in which they are not the sole
driver or the only driver so I would you
know I just would love to kind of think
about that example as a way that we can
get beyond the the sort of bias
conversation because you know I think in
this instance as much as one should feel
I think please that citizens on the
ground likely you know not highly
educated can understand that there have
been these sort of critiques of
algorithm and algorithmic biases that
they don't win the day for what they're
trying to accomplish here and I think
part of you know it falls to us as
scholars partly to I think offer a more
sophisticated rendering
of what sort of the social implications
of algorithms in the world particularly
for vulnerable communities so the
laundry I really appreciate your your
call for us to move beyond bias but I
think one tension that might exist is
the idea that you know all the modern
civil rights literature and many legal
conversations are centered around bias
so to the extent that we want to hold
people accountable and law is usually a
tool holding people accountable how do
we kind of manage the temptation to fall
back on the traditional legal tools that
our premise upon bias frameworks but at
the same time as you're suggesting you
have a more sophisticated framework for
think about how these things are
actually affecting people's lives do we
just have to start over and have a kind
of new generation of civil rights laws
that are much more they're updated to
the current challenges or is there a way
to manage this tension I mean I'm not a
legal scholar and obviously I mean you
and Jonathan can talk to this more but
you know I mean obviously the law bill
it's unprecedented you know you got a
dance with the one who brought me or
whatever that freedom is right that's
what you have to do but but I think even
in the law but even the law I mean I
think even civil rights law is not
biased right um you know that's not what
that's not the sort of lever on which
civil rights claims operate right
there's sort of disparate or not
dispersed intent sometimes there's
issues of intentionality again and
saying this is someone who's not a legal
scholar and so I'm not even sure that
bias is the right conceptual frame for
talking about well certainly in the
individualist framework that his premise
upon one bed act or doing something
horrible to another person what kind of
but as typically in the law a sort of
discrimination right or prejudice rather
than bias just do not just theirs but
that bias is a rather I think new way
right so as you sort of that as long as
the tool is equally discriminatory it
equally captures and captures an
appropriate and faithful representation
or image of everybody then the tool
shouldn't be a problem
I think that's the chest move that's
left to people who latch themselves on
to a is argument right and I think
that's the catch-22 conceptually
theoretically and politically that we're
backing ourselves into you yeah
others have comments on this
so oh do you want so I so I guess I
would pusher argument before further so
I so much so my sense is that so there
are there ways this kind of make
decisions we bias in discrimination and
all the other things that are there my
from our perspective they are a part of
a nexus of way of thinking about the
adverse impact that certain frames are
thinking Kannapolis certain populations
that is premise to pawn at very as I'm
saying earlier individuals framework of
what discrimination is as opposed to a
much more structural approach which
seems to be the direction even though in
terms of how is it that we can have this
kind of predictable adverse outcomes on
certain populations in a way that occur
despite whatever it's someone intends
right so you know I'm all for you know
how do we rethink law in a way that is
more aware and attuned to these broader
structural conversations and you know it
you know people have been having these
conversations law for a long time and I
have made some some some some move
before but I think there's certainly
room to have a much more extensive
conversation about rethinking the way
that law approaches the issue of how
groups in a sense can become repeat
losers because of these have mr.
inventory attitudes so I would be happy
to join you in that quest to think about
it I guess is that I mean one thing that
the law does has is doing better with
regards to these algorithmic systems is
I mean if you think about the wonderful
ProPublica reporting on racial
discrimination algorithms if you think
about Rebecca Wexler's great work on
sort of unpacking the black box of of of
sort of sentencing algorithms and these
sorts of things but I think that doesn't
that still sits on the forensic side and
doesn't sit on the civil rights side you
know so it would be interest so guess
like what I'm you know it's not still
clear to me I'm still trying to think
this through but if we're gonna use the
law as an example what would it mean to
have an understanding of racial bias
that allows us and thinking about legal
situations to marry the the piece around
the black box of the forensic technology
with the
civil rights law peace you know what I
mean as opposed to kind of thinking of
those this it's discrete
Aaron mercy okay so one thing that Aaron
talked about in his comments was this
idea and folks talked about earlier
today is this kind of the fuzziness of a
category of race and race definitions so
just for your own point of view why do
we keep on using these these categories
whenever we all know that they don't
really capture much or at least they
don't capture what we think they might
be they don't capture what we think they
they are speaking to
so so I I can tell you about another
paper that I wrote with Katherine bliss
the sociologists at UCSF across the bay
that was basically it was very similar
kind of set up so so we were looking at
articles in Nature Genetics over
longitudinally and we looked at just
basically what are the labels what are
the population labels that are being
used over time and then we coded these
labels into what is the kind of like
ontology of belonging that they are are
are referring to so and then roughly
these collapse into are they is it a
racial way of labeling a population is
it a geographic way of labeling a
population or is it an ethnic way like a
linguistic ethnic cultural way of
labeling a population and um and one of
the things that has been commented on in
multiple venues but we found happen
increasingly over time is that that
geneticists are very happy to compare an
apple to an orange to a blueberry I mean
they're very happy happy to say this
this you know african-americans we
compared african-americans to people
from Western Belgium to to Ashkenazi
Jews and to find out whether XYZ right
so there's this or or or we compare
people from this region roughly to
people from this race to people from
this ethnic group or you know lots of
different things like that and so one
thing we found is that as as population
as genetics became more of a population
science right so over time one thing
that happens is more articles are about
populations in the comparison of
populations as opposed to being about a
gene and how it works or a set of
molecular pathways right so molecular
biology becomes less what
genetics is about and and it's more
about population genetics and but
there's more of a tendency to combine
and compare these different logics of
what a population is in a particular
study and it's what kind of
fundamentally kind of puzzling so what
are you actually comparing what are you
saying is genetic right what are you
saying
is typical of like what's a group and
this is happening at the same time as
Joan was saying like that that that
these folks are claiming to be the
science of population right we this is
their the authoritative science about
population you want to jump it
particular authors first to in terms of
their willingness compared and an apple
to an orange blueberry versus comparing
like cohorts that are collected by very
like getting your hands like forward
looking for very different people yeah
yeah okay
so so that so you're anticipating one of
my one of my results right so then we
like basically sort of documented this
and then we interviewed a got interview
data about like what are you doing and
when you're trying to label these
populations and why why are you doing
this so so there are I think they're
basically two findings one was this
opportunism which is like it's easier
just to throw it all into a model and
we're and to collaborate with lots of
different groups then to try to convince
other groups that our ontology is
correct right and so sometimes they'll
say like you know we really don't like
it when they use Caucasian we don't we
and and but they are in the criminal
justice field we're in the health field
we don't use that but in the criminal
justice field that's the way
everything's coded and they think that
that's the right way to do things so
it's better just to agree to disagree
and get the publication out right rather
than figure out what what it is that's
one thing another thing is that they
said that you know there are all these
promulgated standards by these journals
like okay we should no longer use this
kind of race we should label in this way
in this way and a lot of them said you
know
or so NIH has has rules about how you
supposed to collect and label your data
as so does soda journal about how you
disclose and describe things and a lot
of them were just like screw the
journals screw the bureaucrats this is
partly our we're claiming our authority
to just sort of do our research the way
we want right we're we're doing in part
to resist this imposition from others
who are not scientists trying to tell us
what a population is and then a third
thing was so that was kind of an
authority grab but they also talked
about not wanting to real able
populations partly because the politics
of population genetics and not telling
people who they are right so they don't
like to real able as partly as an
accountability measure to the
populations that they're studying they
don't like to real able those populate
those samples in different ways than
what people tell them they are when they
collect the data does that make sense
right and part of that there's
convenient yes right and so I think that
part of it so there's this sort of like
combination of different motives that
are going on that kind of keep the
wheels turning and allow and and then
the last thing is that their favorite is
to use continental labeling continental
labels and this is the most ambiguous
form of label because it's is it a
geographic label or is it a racial label
and they liked to leave that undefined
so it's not just that they don't know
and they don't know so sometimes this is
something that dueña found right that
when you ask them well what is race they
couldn't really tell you so some of it
is that they can't tell you but some of
it also is that they don't want like
they don't want to peel it back and
actually make the make a statement about
what it is and it's better to use this
kind of quasi geographic quasi racial
set of labels and combine them with
others because it allows you to speak
about race without speaking about race
I somebody raised that maybe it was
humorous he raised the issue of
polygenic scores earlier so with my SSRC
hat on with some with a couple of
colleague at Harvard with Evelyn and two
geneticists we you know did a kind of
closed workshop around apologetic scores
around the issues of racial
classification and a space of I don't
know if you call you know what is them
our colleague Katherine Bliss calls it
socio genomics you might call it Susie
biology a lots of things you could call
it but these sort of research teams of
social scientists computer scientists
sometimes geneticists who are using
these big G wasps and genetic databases
to you know for some it's actually just
a math exploit or it's a statistical
exploit which is you know which is fine
but I guess the the sort of challenge I
guess one of a lots of things came up in
these workshops that one of the things
came up is that there have been a few
papers around important papers New York
Times front page above the fold papers
on educational attainment and and
genetics that I've come out and these
have been you know papers that are
making claims about race but the claims
but the data set is the UK biobank right
which is not a racially regionally
ethnically
continentally whatever you know diverse
a database includes or at least they
exclude non-white yeah and moreover I
mean one of the things yes but one of
the things that came out in the
conversations I mean the conversations
were fascinating for so many reasons
because you had like you know you had
statisticians and people who are doing
sort of bio information and you had just
sort of you know sort of geneticists and
sort of no one could kind of there was a
lot of just noise and contestation
around the methodology which we as
social scientists found very interesting
but but one of the interesting things is
that you know literally in this data set
it distinguishes between like sardine
Ian's and you know like French or
whatever and so but these date but
what's coming out of the back end are
papers that say racial differences in X
or Y not like the paper doesn't say like
the differences between Sardinians and
Greeks
right and so there's also you know this
this this sort of easy move from a data
set that's fairly you know homogenous
right to sort of fairly big claims about
kind of racial racial differences and
various kinds of social attributes so
that's you know another way in which
this this works and it's not just about
sloppy conceptualization it's also just
really playing fast and loose with the
data
and just another translational issue
here and you know we try to I think
we're pleased we're really interested in
the way that these ideas that emerge
from scholarship and from labs get
translated into actual products that are
sold to regular people like the ones
that we saw well one of the things
that's happening with polygenic scores
now is guess what there's a company
called predictive no genomic prediction
right genomics it's hard to get it right
and this is a company that is offering
up its service is that it will do
genetic analysis of the embryos that you
have created with your partner or your
donor or gamete provider and it will
tell you what the polygenic score of
each of the embryos is for educational
attainment so again we're boiling it
down to one number and on that basis
we're gonna just tell you which embryos
you should not use to develop into your
child now this the the guy who runs this
company Stephen Hsu who's the Dean of
research at Michigan State University he
says that for ethical reasons they're
not going to tell you which is the
highest polygenic score and we oh they
just want to tell you the low scoring
embryos so he does have some ethical
standards great so our last question
before we take questions from the
audience is so what role can academic or
public policy institutions play and
bringing the correct framework on race
and racism to developers of algorithms
and to the public as a whole
this is actually a question that I'm
actually really fascinated about with
respect to this audience okay so in this
workshop that Alondra talked about a lot
of the geneticists the population
geneticists there were extremely nervous
about this idea of portability so so the
idea was can you take a polygenic
prediction that's that's the training
data is say the UK biobank and then can
you transport that over to you know
African Americans in the United States
or can you translate that over to Han
Chinese and for and so they were they
showed us all sorts of very technical
explanations for why you cannot do that
especially because of population
stratification basically genetic
population stratification and and and
there but so there's an interesting
thing that has happened historically in
the year that I think I think they all
thought that that population
stratification problem is gonna get
smaller and smaller and it was gonna be
solved pretty soon and what are we gonna
do about it and I think it's turned out
that the the history's gone the other
direction that the population
stratification problem has gotten bigger
and bigger and it's turned out that
there's incredible amounts of population
stratification even within ethnically
homogenous populations so that like if
you train the data on people that are 50
years old it doesn't translate to the
same population of people that are 20
years old right like so it's turning out
that it might be the other direction
that actually population stratification
is way worse rather than better but okay
so that so to those population
geneticists they're like whoo you know I
think that they're feeling like okay
that means that we cannot make these
kind of pernicious racial comparisons
legitimately and we don't have to worry
as much about it but the other thing is
there's no reason why you cannot
calculate the polygenic risk score even
on another population and and there are
people in the field of behavioral
genetics that are on the margins as I
was saying before that have done so and
have done a graph of you know you know
national population versus polygenic
score and they show that the you know
African populations have low polygenic
scores and European populations of high
polygenic scores and Mediterranean
populations are somewhere in the middle
you know QED genes for racial
superiority and we're talking about the
educational attainment data and it's not
surprising that you'll get that pattern
as a complete artifact of population
stratification but there's no reason why
you can't calculate it and plot it and
then promulgate it and this goes back to
you know and white nationalists have
picked up on this stuff others have
picked up on that stuff and so okay so -
so oh and and also these data are being
like you can upload your 23andme data to
Spotify or it's actually ancestry data
to Spotify and they will make a DNA
playlist for you or at least in the old
days they would I don't know if they
still do it I think they might have been
some background yeah oh and they'll tell
you that okay so okay cool so now these
data are available so it may not be
legitimate from the point of view of a
Harvard or University of Chicago
population geneticists to make these
inferences great for them but what about
Spotify what about just some machine
learning scientist who's not a
population geneticist or an economist
what about others right so like what
about the folks that like you know you
can do it you can calculate it so what
do we do so what is the what are the
like how do we prevent misuses when you
can start simply just like and run it
through a machine and get your outputs
didn't censor do so
well I think this is such an important
question for the folks here I mean the
folks here who come from come to the
computer sciences the life sciences and
who are sitting here all day talking
about these social issues and issues of
racial justice and issues of racism
instructional inequality you're the ones
that care and about this stuff and then
you know one of the important messages
it seems to me is that we just have to
acknowledge and we have to have people
who do this and their daily lives
acknowledge that science exists within
these struck social structures within
these relationships of power and
hierarchy and that single point I think
if more people really you know digested
that I think we would be so much further
ahead in being able to use these tools
in in Liberatore ways rather than
oppressive ways and it runs up against
something really strong that's going on
in our political sphere right now which
is the idea that when we talk about
science being politicized that's a bad
thing and the only people who politicize
scientists are the science are the
right-wingers so you know I take my dog
around the block and every other house
has the sign that says you know in this
house everyone is welcome black lives
matter and science is real what does
that mean but that has really become a
kind of a mantra of liberal and
progressive politics right now and it
makes me so uncomfortable and if I you
know I I feel like we need a way of
talking about that that you know
acknowledges the attacks from the right
wing they are real and they are awful
but doesn't take refuge just like you
know the 20th century version of bias
you know being
yeah people this is some I don't know
nineteen Enlightenment ideas simple
fairytale about the Enlightenment and
everything about the Enlightenment is
great and I think it underlies a lot of
the problems that we have you're talking
about these things that we're talking
about today
okay great any other comments on this so
I think we have a few minutes for
questions from the audience I went on
your hand up was earlier did you want to
raise a question okay I said I just
calling people all right uh Nancy
real tight 15 20 minutes go for it
is really short because I know I've
spoken before but I want to really
follow up on your point Marcy and
especially in relation to this whole
panel which has been really useful to
hear which is I think it is critical to
be aware that there is science meant as
a field of work which is independent
researchers independently testing ideas
but the question is which ideas premise
Don what frameworks and their long
history of scientific racism mean that's
as much a part of the history of what
science as anti-racist science so
therefore being to be clear and what the
assumptions are and I completely agree
with your concerns of just saying
science is real isn't enough and I've
been concerned about some of the
mobilizing that's been happening around
marches for science in that kind of way
and the questions that were coming up
before us to who has authority or not
so at this coming American Public Health
Association meeting the spirit of 1848
caucus which for those of you not
familiar we linked issues of social
justice and public health and have been
doing it we're actually having our 25th
anniversary the whole frame is around
what does it mean to be for science now
and it's actually about taking on
anti-racist and anti colonial science
and that's through the forms of both
social history of science but also
progressive pedagogy but also the
politics of public health data so I
think that's really crucial of how do we
talk about doing critical science
without throwing science out the window
and saying it's just all a matter of
stories and anybody's story's as good as
anybody else's story because that's not
so helpful either
and so I but I think this is really
important and I think Calandra to your
point related to this is that it's
really important again to historicism
oment that we're in so it's it's
different in the world of racial
discrimination there's not the laws that
are being passed right now saying it's
ok to delete lay discriminate as there
are for example around LGBTQ stuff so
you're gonna have moments where it's the
actual legal policies that are under
context and you can look at how that's
affecting the different health outcomes
but bringing in that historical
framework about what's embodied and the
continued impact of the historical
redlining and the continued impact of
Jim Crow for example that's really
relevant and I think my sense is that a
lot of people in the here-and-now think
that was all a long time ago and it's no
longer relevant to understanding that
concurrent conditions and I remember
vividly one conversation with one
political scientist was like well we all
know race doesn't isn't a real category
so let's get rid of it and we'll just be
fine and I'm like imagine you whoa you
waved a magic wand right now and all of
a sudden all forms of inequity were gone
except everybody was still in their same
bodies does it not matter it would still
matter in terms of the health outcomes
it would still matter in terms of the
services needed would still matter in
the way that who what matters for the
next generation so I think bringing that
historical awareness of the moment of
now in the context of really real bodies
in which we live our lives and express
the conditions in which we've grown up
and which will continue going forward is
really important thank you
I just wanted to build on what Nancy was
saying and Alondra I so appreciated your
message to us because I do think these
issues are very much go much much deeper
than separating out bad science from
good science the right uses of science
from the misuses of science and so on so
you brought us to the fact that it's not
a matter of algorithms or biased but
algorithms are racialized by the very
structures of which how society operates
like everything else and I'm very
reminded at this moment I haven't seen
Evelyn for 25 years or something like
that we were trying to figure it out it
feels to me very much like conversations
we were having decades ago when we were
talking about feminist science studies
and the ways in which it was very
important to come up with new and usable
ideas of objectivity we're you know just
to bring back in some of the
conversation also from earlier this
afternoon what Jonathan's point not so
much about having science tell the law
about whether we should do affirmative
action or not but showing that from the
get-go there are always operative
assumptions
Justin stating a fact and that something
like you know affirmative action is
necessary for surfacing the assumptions
that are otherwise dormant and doing
their work and that I do think that
there is a way very much to talk about
the kinds of alternative notions of of
objectivity within for example feminist
epistemologies which can really address
things like your concern Marcy and the
concern that Nancy was also raising
about the ways in which at a moment of
time like this we want to both say yes
to science but not the science as usual
right yes to science and you know let's
really push on the science as well
because there this can be a moment for
radicalizing science or at least I'd
like to think so
so since this is the Polly policy
section I just wanted to ask given
everything we've seen today like all the
ways in which algorithms do bad things
but also even that we're here in the Bay
Area where you know you have companies
come and not really give have a sense of
how they're hurting a community as
opposed to helping the community that
they're implanting themselves in or
whether we give all these apps that
their goal is to disrupt but not ask who
they're disrupting or which communities
are disrupting or in what ways they're
disrupting I just want to ask it feels a
lot with all of these algorithms and
apps and all these technologies that
were kind of in the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution again before we
got all the regulations we said hey
child labor isn't so good neither is
monopolies and so on so I want to ask
are there general regulations that we
should start think you know for these
technologies and especially for this
audience
what definitions do you need from us
theoretical computer scientists and just
the theoretical foundations of
algorithmic fairness what kind of
definitions would you need to have
well-defined regulations that are
general as opposed to attacking each
software engineering team in each
company one by one and calling them out
responses I love that question I mean I
think that you know it's a so look we've
had sort of other moments of kind of
hi-tech knock recei and high bureaucracy
but it is very much a moment for
computer scientists to lead in the
policy space I mean we're you know so I
write about health activists who in the
1960s and early 70s who were engaged in
health activism around genetics issues
and that was a moment in which people
with non-experts could engage
conversations about genetic science I
feel you know we are in you know with
you know planning a flag around
Jonathan's conversation about battling
expertise earlier today and a moment of
kind of very elite sort of technological
policymaking and technological apparatus
is that very few people have access to
including a lot of very smart people
with PhDs in this room who are not CS
folks right and so it really you know
it's at you know it falls I think a lot
falls on the cs community to you know
there we can understand sort of
conceptually operationally what's
happening around classification and
choosing categories and kind of basic
things around algorithms but to get to
the meat of you know algorithmic systems
that are impacting policies takes a
level of expertise that fewer and fewer
people have myself as someone who
studies bioethics you know part of
reasons why I do the work that I do is
because you know the field of bioethics
emerged in response to a recognition
that one of the most horrific moments in
human history was facilitated because of
a lack of oversight of science and
technology and a field emerged in part
to say you know never again that we're
gonna kind of have some type of some
type of professional oversight to make
sure that our certain rules and
guidelines that we have to make sure
that this type of lease-up outcomes
don't happen and you know fast forward
several decades you know we see a
similar type of lack of regulation and
oversight not only in the fields
science and medicine but any other areas
of technology that can produce some
really catastrophic outcomes and so you
the question you're asking is you know
where's the oversight and quite frankly
we're all you know asleep at the wheel
on this and you know part of the work
that I try to do and advocate is that we
need a lot really many more people
participate in the conversation not just
as specialists not just people with PhDs
but a much more a process that is
democrat that is inclusive in a
democratic sense to make sure as you
were saying that the people who may be
affected by this are part of the
conversation so that these technologies
can develop in a way that can support
and improve human life and not take away
from it okay I just want to add one last
thing which is I think what's also
really important to think about is the
sort of political imaginaries that are
animating the impulses to produce things
and to think about how we would regulate
them so so one thing is that I think
that a lot of the terms that we use to
discuss these things privacy individual
autonomy and so forth you know not that
I'm against privacy but I'm not sure
that it's it's it's a covering principle
that actually gets everything we need I
think that this is one of the
conversations that's been happening in
bioethics for examples that this sort of
so on the one hand the sort of the the
the the the dimensions of like
individual autonomy informed consent and
so forth are great but they're limited
right and we need to expand those out
but I also think that one thing that's
happening right now is that there's a
battle in the Silicon Valley more
broadly between a libertarian imaginary
right which is that fundamentally you
know oversight and regulation are bad
breaking things in and asking asking for
forgiveness not for permission and that
there's no one more competent than us so
why should we have any accountability to
anyone else that that's one imaginary
and then I think that that's partly
generational partly not i partly
distributed throughout but i think that
there are other imaginaries and right
which is a social justice imaginary a
social socialist imaginary others that
that might be fighting with that and so
anyway I just think
important for us before we even think
about like what are the regulations but
what are the regulatory imaginary
marries and this links to I think things
just to build one more brick on those
comments we we get a lot of calls that
the Center for genetics and society for
reporters who want to talk to us about
what's wrong with genetic databases of
various kinds Katie takes a lot of these
call and we've had this conversation
where we really want to talk to them
about the sort of structural issues that
come up around race and how the ancestry
tests and how the the 23andme es are in
criminate in those kinds of issues and
in feeding this these resurgent ideas
that races genetic erases biological and
they want to talk about privacy concerns
you know so it really is a shift that
needs to happen and trying to ask you a
question for quite a while now and you
keep calling on your friends right so go
ahead and call on her or whatever no I'm
just saying this is a pattern you keep
calling on the same people people you
know and other people are not given a
chance to speak I don't know if this is
intentional but you seem to know the
names of everybody you call pretty much
no question that
he was actually also over there with his
hand up for about 10 minutes and wasn't
called these asked your question okay
quick question the war we're fighting
right now is political and economic and
we will not win it unless science stops
trying to defend science and starts
trying to defend the people who are now
being poisoned and otherwise suffering
can you say something more about how
your expertise might be used to change
policy because we need to change
governance thank you
I mean I think that so the one thing
that I could say is that I think that
part of what we want to do is is
combined combine different forms of
expertise to - you know disrupt the the
ordinary ways the things that Nancy was
saying earlier about defending science
right as an abstract thing and that
marce you saying right that that you
know science is an autonomous thing that
has it so that it needs to be kowtow to
and and and honored right so part of I
think what we're doing here today and I
think in other venues like this is to
think about how to disrupt that idea
that science has its own logic or
internal coherence that it needs to be
just respected but that it's embedded
and entangled in all sorts of other
social relations and so I I don't that's
the way that I think about what we can
do here rather than giving a sort of set
of regulatory principles starting a
conversation about how to entangle
different forms of expertise in
different sets of imaginaries of
servicing
I wanted to pick up on some of the
questions about language and terminology
and like frames and we were talking we
were talking about ethics and kind of
asleep at the wheel bioethics seems to
have gotten an enormous amount of
traction within the people who practice
medicine healthcare generally and it's
been very interesting as somebody I
practice and I'm a lawyer but I make a
lot of common cause of people who think
about values and technical design and
they are the computer ethicists don't
seem to have kind of gotten as embraced
or embedded and the technical
disciplines but it's been super
interesting to see the theoreticians and
I would say the computer science field
more generally embrace concepts like
privacy they define them in particular
ways that may not or you know may or may
not fully embrace what we're looking at
or embrace an issue like fairness and
come all right all of these definitions
and for me as a lawyer at AI I think
often in terms of Human Rights and that
seems to right now in much of the
Silicon Valley being kind of displaced
by a conversation about ethics which for
me in fact makes me very uncomfortable
because I think it's a shift away from
accountability and to a level of kind of
ambiguity about what right outcomes
there I think ethics suggest that well
we're all trying to do the right thing
we just have different frames where the
language of Human Rights has a much more
kind of accountability and a very
legalistic framing so I was just
interested in the communities kind of
reflections on what are the right terms
to be using like you bias I'm more
interested in justice I think it takes
the frame from is it about a better
algorithm or is it about systematic
surveillance I don't I actually view
bias and facial recognition algorithms
that's a bonus and and so I just you
know wanted to hear you talk a little
bit more about the words that we're
choosing and the and how they relate to
the frames that we might think about and
how those in themselves suggest
different kinds
mediations
so I'll just say that so the story about
bioethics is not necessarily a happy one
and you have to keep my comments short I
think there have been several people
writing about this including folks like
Carl Elliot wrote a great book called
white coat black hat or all the way
around black hat like so excited stories
tells us to worry about a field that
emerged in the mid 20th century to be a
check on the life sciences but then you
know fast were a few decades and
actually became complicit in some of the
horrific things that folks and life
sciences were doing and I think the
concern we look at other technologies
that is that a similar pattern might
emerge where as you know we have a
important conversation about regulating
industry and an industry and then you
know things get messy and all of a
sudden the folks who are supposed to be
overseeing things become complicit in
the development of technologies that
mean quite harmful so part of this
conversation it's how do we kind of make
sure that the the effort at oversight is
meaningful substantive and long-lasting
and and separate from the folks were
actually doing development I mean there
always has to be a relationship but
making sure there's a level of
separation but I think your question
about I think ultimately your second
part a question about what are our
values is it is a bias is it justice
yeah I think that's a that's a critical
conversation to have but again that
can't just be a conversation happens in
the boardrooms of certain corporations
it has to be a public democratic
conversation and the frameworks and the
terms do matter
so bioethics really has come to mean to
focus on relationships one-to-one
relationship so you know one to small
group relationships so it's the patients
and the doctor it's the research
subjects of the researcher and that's in
so you have you know focus on informed
consent and autonomy but you don't have
focus on structures on social structures
and on social justice and on and human
rights you know with a claim to be some
universal have some universal things to
say about that rather than just yeah I'm
trying to be an ethical person just very
simply I think one thing Epic's is about
inputs or right actions
justice is about outputs or
and like we often talk about well if you
act right if you're ethical in your
actions okay but anyway but anyway so I
feel like the justice framework is more
and I think that that is justice is
something that bioethicists say is a
value but they are not very good at
articulating it for operation or
operation yeah I just one thing which is
that you know bias fairness ethics have
been you know words we've used forever
but like have become very powerful and
taking up a certain kind of space right
now so just from a political perspective
it begs the question about whether or
not I'm even though it's the it's what
we what some of us mean is justice the
both best vocabulary for shifting a
discourse away from bias the bias and
ethics so I don't I don't know what the
answer to that is but it's worth kind of
I think for us thinking about a new
vocabulary that can sort of shift the
conversation from bias and ethics that
have really taken at all of the space
how much time do we have
shall we take so we have we have a
reception that started so what's that
thing doing school is you know I like to
always make sure if there are graduates
or undergrads in the audience if they
have a question make sure to face space
for them to ask that question so any
students we have a comment or a question
want a response or respond or offer a
comment or perspective on the question
on language because I'm thinking about
this a lot I'm in philosophy in math and
I think when you say human rights you
know if you read Sam Moines history of
human rights that's a strong indictment
of the term and so there you have human
rights taking up you know kind of taking
up the mantle like a kind of weak mantle
of Justice after the you know falling
away of maximalist visions of global
justice with the new international
economic order and so there when I hear
human rights I'm like that's not the
language you want to use and in my kind
of like an interest in political
philosophy you know what we want least
what I'm interested in is like the
actual reclaiming of moral language in a
space in which neoliberalism has largely
evacuated out a moral language from
moving kind of everything from an
economic or everything from political
register to an economic writer so what
do we actually give up when we say that
there isn't fundamentally some political
capacity in our languages and I think I
think conversations about language are
important because they're conversations
about strategy but they're not
conversations I think about the
intrinsic value of concepts because then
we're kind of we're left in thinking
that if we kind of just choose the right
language then we're going to kind of not
do the political agitation I just think
that that's also kind of itself a wrong
strategy so there's kind of a meta
strategy level there's like a strategy
level at language there's like a meta
strategy level about what to do about
the you know vacuum of language and what
to do about dominant language it just
like happens to be their genealogically
and happens to be well more communicated
and how we're all still like operating
in our own position a letís about which
language is more powerful
yes in the back we don't really say like
banking for good
like there even the words themselves
have an association you know like the
work we saw earlier what are the
adjectives that you have to add how do
you describe someone and AI even though
it's a totally expansive word its idea
but we can't tell you what it is and
what it isn't so we have to add a value
because part of its power is this
disjoint between what it is how can we
communicate about it translationally and
what what the uses are so as an AI
natural language processing research
scientists I my I get very concerned
when I see AI for good the same way you
see what does that mean can we can they
not be in is the concept too big to also
include ethical reasoning
this is a question for all of the
panelists and thank you for a really
rich discussion so Alondra is kind of
asking us to think beyond bias I think
of course is really important I love the
last comment from the student over here
I guess one of the Sheridan's issues I
see between genomics and the data
sciences or what I would call the
algorithmic turn is the question of
informed consent and I'm wondering if
you know Shoshanna
Zubov Swarek on surveillance capitalism
and the way she poses decision rights
actually helps a shift semantic field in
the direction of thinking about it's not
our right to say that we opt in to
facial recognition technology but that
we learn to recognize what's being
performed upon us without our consent
and often against our will and also what
is being extracted from us so I think
especially in the fields of genomics you
can sign up for you and me 23 but that
information is being accessed by 3rd 4th
and 5th parties and I also thought the
comment in the back I think from the CS
student what are you asking us for in
terms of thinking about regulations it
is like this new moment of that is akin
to industrial capital where there is
rampant unregulated and I think the
regulation question was so important so
if any of you could reflect on some
small part of it
when this is with my social science
research council hat on part of why I
have to leave in a few minutes is I have
to go you know we've been working on a
project that's trying to create a
systematic pathway for social
researchers to study Facebook data and
you know one of the things that's been
fascinating in this project is that all
of the projects that come to us for peer
review are either exempted or mostly
exempted or expedited from peer review
right and so you know the regulatory
framework even for the ethics of the
research we do is completely lagged
slash failed right so you know we have
created as a condition of the work that
everything has to go through IRB or its
international equivalent everything
comes in expedited right there's like
there are no human subjects here there
are no human or public harms there's no
what so the IRB is like why are you even
sending this to us like why you know
here's your letter and like you know
apply for the data so as an organization
we've kind of created our own internal
kind of ethics review process but I
think to the point around bioethics it's
not only about sort of how do we get
more kind of harness you know harness
surveillance capitalism regulations it's
also about our sort of lack of courage
and therefore lag around regulation that
we think that we have right and it's
also the case that part of what the
algorithmic turn brings is a move to
network and collective harms and so the
model of bioethics which was Marcy was
saying is very much about the individual
individual relationships between actors
and clinical spaces and other things you
know don't apply I mean any genetic
ancestry test is about you and anybody
bio related to you you know by design
you know there's nothing you can do
about that so you know we're in a and I
guess and this is what - to Karen's
point I mean I think your work is is
kind of an example of what I'm talking
about I mean I we've got to get I think
out of our way and the fact that your
work which was like there are objects
there's materiality and people were like
that's radical let's you know go with
that as a feminist you know epistemology
he was like I think we're facing another
moment like that
around you know kind of racial politics
and kind of issues of justice with
regards to the algorithmic turn and so I
would offer you know I'd agree with you
but after your own work as a in a prior
moment as a kind of another moment that
we need to have so I don't know with a
advocacy hat on I mean we also really
need the advocacy groups to take on
these questions some of them to you know
emerge like you know the site the
science for the people group that was
the radical science group in the 1970s
is just relaunching the magazine and I
don't know that much about it but I was
thought it was a good sign but we also
need to work with the existing advocacy
groups across the range of sectors and
really bring these questions because I
think those are the people that get it
in their gut that you know these are
questions about what kind of world are
we building what kind of future doing
winel live and that's really what we're
asking here
so about the comment about computer
scientists kind of leading or being
involved in these kind of regulations
and I think there's a lot of openness by
certainly my community which is the
radical computer scientist and towards
being part of this kind of endeavor and
and and we understand the limitation of
what we can do and we understand the
multidisciplinary nature of that but I
think we at times getting kind of these
mixed signals from various other
communities that we are trying to
collaborate with and where there is a
lot of suspicion towards what we do and
what we can do and what we can offer
suspicion that kind of goes into these
words like math I mean math cannot do
that math cannot to death
and suspicions about so it's not as
efficient towards the particular
approach that we're suggesting but a
suspicion about our entire toolbox and
what it can do and and its limitations
that we are aware of but we still feel
as important a role to play in this and
so our our fight is not only towards the
practitioners of the engineers the
companies but also towards the
communities with which we want to
collaborate
so it's a hand so to the so Larry Oh
like this this may be an unfair question
at the end of the day but to bring it
back to translation you know this has
been extremely informative for me about
how new technologies the algorithms that
are rien scribing old ideas of race as
they make biology but what we haven't
done is talk about how we can rupture
that discourse what perhaps are the key
scientific ideas and evidence that could
be persuasive to a general audience do
with the general public because that
could have an equal amount of weight
it's hopefully more and bringing back in
and suturing together a new discourse
which looks up around human diversity
[Laughter]
yeah she'd be sisters
should we just collect a series of
questions all at once okay last thing
between you and wine I'll be brief I
just wanted to circle back for a minute
to become discussion around semantics
and bioethics I've been I do a lot of
work in that area semantics in bioethics
and I think it's really important to
point out that informed consent is
something we assume we're entitled to in
this country but it's been eroded at an
escalating pace we're losing it and the
right to informed consent is being
replaced in a way that's being catalyzed
by semantics changes you know where
bioethics is now engaged with a new type
of new speak to the point where we have
all these types of consent that have no
element of consent
you know deferred consent consent after
the fact they say consent but they don't
involve you actually giving your payment
you're we right to say yes or no to
anything since 1996 when the law was
first changed to allow a medical
research with unconscious patients
without their consent we've been seeing
this escalating a lot in languages a lot
to do with it last year when certain
words were banned seven words were
banned from essentially from by medical
researchers those words are quite
significant they reflect a bias they
reflect the point of view and they are
crippling and researchers abilities even
ask certain questions so I think it's
really important to when we think about
bioethics to understand that the words
that sounds so noble everybody agrees
are good things are often impotent you
know everyone's for fairness for example
but what is fairness it means nothing
unless you have actually defined it and
enforced it and that's not
happening increasingly often so like
once so someone who looks for
definitions can you help with that Siri
I'm serious we have to talk
all right last one this is a really
specific and pointed question because
you're the policy people so devices
medical devices are regulated the
government regulates them right doctors
are a self-regulating body if a doctor
does something and a patient dies groups
of doctors meet up and decide if that
doctor did the right or wrong thing
right so where do you see some of these
things we've been talking about right
this border of machine learning you know
it's is it a device is it approximating
a doctor where do you see the regulation
of that and I think specifically coming
from a bioethics background where would
you want to see that versus where do you
think it's going to end up I don't think
we want to you know have a relationship
between you know the designer of the
relational database model and what those
databases are used for today that as
there is between a doctor who violates
her code of ethics in the way that her
patient is treated I think it's a
different kind of relationship so I
don't think that there's you know
there's an easy translation there I
think that some of the gaps in the way
that we regulate biomedical innovation
are telling and are more like well the
problems we face in the world of
computer science and algorithms are so
for example medical devices are
regulated to their as to their safety
and efficacy but questions about social
consequences and effects certainly
ethics and values those questions are
not considered in any kind of regulatory
oversight right now in the United States
in other countries there are some little
ways you can you know smush those
questions in but here the FDA by law may
not consider anything beyond safety and
efficacy and once the thing the device
or the drug is out in the world then
it's in the doctor's bailiwick and the
doctor
can use it off-label so that some of the
problems that we have in the biomedical
sphere come out of that and you know
that's what's going on now in the
computer world you know the technologies
exist they've been let out in the world
they are making gobs of money for some
companies and individuals and you know
we didn't envision it any more than we
envisioned when we took the first barrel
of oil out of the ground with an oil
well we didn't envision you know a
network of highways and lost luggage at
the airport and certainly not
catastrophic climate change but we have
to get better at that we have to I think
that's one of the points we really have
to get better at looking at the
trajectory of these powerful powerful
technologies and where is it taking us
as societies and and different ones
among us in them but in the stratified
societies that we live in we have to get
better at asking those questions and
steering it things the way we believe
they should go I'll just speak very
precisely I think that actually we're in
a moment of transition I think 23andme
has just actually like broken the sort
of regulatory idea about what a
predictive algorithm is right I mean I
think I don't remember four years ago
when 23andme three years ago when
23andme was given the kind of cease and
desist from the FDA saying you are
marketing a medical device and you need
to stop doing that and they appealed
that in etc etc etc and now basically it
seems like I think they convinced the
FDA partly through a kind of like
hands-off regulatory regime that's been
sort of introduced that algorithmic
prediction of health outcomes is not a
medical device it's not like an x-ray
it's not like other things and so you
can do it and so so I think that they
basically had a decision made and
basically that gave a lot of freedom
that's good as my sense is it's going to
establish a precedent that allows a lot
of freedom for algorithmic prediction in
the medical space so watch out
okay
[Applause]